the difference is now they have the
option not to do it no but what's the
difference now is hypergamies on
steroids right now yeah yeah but then
you're going to get to the point of
where where you're gonna you're gonna do
all this for your 20s and if you don't
cash out if you don't select a guy
you're gonna get in your 30s and then
you're going to be competing with the
women in the 22s that don't mind
actually having a guy with a kid so now
automatically you're on your 30 saying I
don't want a guy with a kid then you've
got a girl that's in 22. I agree with
you I said she doesn't mind I I agree
with you but my point is that like I
think standards are higher than ever
before and that's why like that's why
there's so many shows based off of this
[ __ ] because you think in 1950 that the
women there were saying six feet six
figures six inches no they want to marry
Joe Joe down the block okay people say
he's got a secure job it's harder than
ever for men to get sex the small
percentage of men sure
sure the the good looking man over six
foot with good job sure